I have three rules of life
frivolous though they may sound
one is a man's going to know his
limitations Dirty Harry
second is if you think if you can't
deduct it don't spend it and you can't
always do that but a lot of times you
can't and third and this is very
important it's going to sound really
stupid but it can be applied to a lot of
things
remember the old mummy movies
The Mummy is
and he's always the guy always runs into
a cul-de-sac or something or stumbles or
something and gets killed by The Mummy
Okay the third rule if you can't outrun
The Mummy you deserve to get killed
get yourself all hooked on drugs you did
that to yourself nobody forces usually
to do that except in horror movies where
they strap you down they give you an
injection and I see so many people that
destroy their lives on drugs or alcohol
or whatever it is
um they're not out running that mummy
you know and it's hard to feel sorry for
them